leaving as fast as they can people fled
the northeastern city of sumi trying to
get out before nightfall when a
ceasefire ends
the night before airstrikes hit
residential buildings and a power plant
local authorities said 21 people were
killed
further west people fleeing the city of
erpine close to the capital kiev
crossing a damaged bridge that russian
troops have repeatedly fired on as
civilians tried to get across
heartbreaking goodbyes as many of the
men split up from their families to go
back and fight
others helping those unable to make the
journey by themselves
she is barely walking but we are doing
our best thank you
it is good that we could cross the
bridge
bombs are exploding over there quite
intense
is totally damaged
meanwhile in the capitol
president volody miyazalenski refusing
to flee
a video message to his people trying to
prepare them for the days to come
snow is falling
this is spring
the war is the same as spring
severe
but it will be all right
we will win anyway
military analysts say the russian
onslaught will likely get worse in the
coming days russian forces are
increasingly turning to shelling
civilian areas and infrastructure
while their tanks and troops are bogged
down outside key cities
in the port city of odessa residents are
mounting barricades in front of the
beloved opera house
so far the city hasn't been hit
but if the experience of the last
several days is any guide
anyone who stays behind should be
prepared for the worst
let's go to our correspondent matthias
berlinger in kiev mathias what's the
situation this morning in the capital
it's uh as always very calm in the
capital uh still the fighting is limited
to those suburbs that you mentioned
european and bucha and the area around
that airport and also troops are
advancing from the east but the city
center has so far been spared of heavy
fighting and also mostly not not
completely but uh mostly of heavy
bombing the city is still open it's
impossible to leave the city and to get
into the city and supplies are still
getting into the city so life is tense
here but still possible
many civilians have been rescued from
the besieged city of sumer
what about mariopol in the south
that looks a lot worse than sumitsuma is
already quite bad and many people have
died there as well trying to escape the
city but
mariopol is very very dire it's
completely surrounded it's been
completely surrounded for more than a
week now and uh
electricity has been cut water supplies
have been cut we've seen pictures of
children dying of dehydration and
supplies are running low people are
trying to survive on what's left there
it's very very very dire
matthias can you give us an idea of
where we're at in this battle as i
mentioned before
ukraine's army says it's managed to slow
the advance of russian forces
which are suffering major setbacks
it depends on what you see as the
how you measure it the idea of the
russian army seems to have been to take
kiev quickly and then
have the government surrender and take
control of the country that has clearly
not worked resistance has been fierce to
this this russian advance the ukrainian
army has been able to destroy a lot of
russian military tech technology and
also
uh
many russian soldiers have died or have
been captured so
they they have uh uh
the the russian army has considerable
losses but there is oscar also uh
it's also very clear that the russian
army is outnumbering the ukrainians they
have more supplies that they can bring
in so this is now a battle of two armies
wearing each other out this is what it
is about and whether the ukraine can
continue to resist the russian army will
of course depend on its supplies uh on
the morale which is still very high
and russia is advancing but very slowly
mathias berlinger appreciate the update
thank you very much
maria aptiva lives in kharkiv and works
at the european expert association
focusing on ukrainian relations with the
eu and nato
firstly could you tell us about your
personal situation this morning and how
bad the destruction is in har kiev
yes i am staying in kharkiv and every
day i try to go out on the streets to
show the world what is happening in
kharkiv because we see that russian
media tries to show very different
picture and they try to hide what is
actually happening in this city and call
this russian war here a special military
operation so i go around and take videos
and protestors to have this evidences of
the war crimes committed here in kharkiv
there are major destructions in the city
center because it was heavily bombarded
and the historical some of the
historical buildings are completely
destroyed as the main administrative
building which was the symbol of kharkiv
and also the uh residential areas are
destroyed and i can see that the uh
pipelines and the uh energy is off so
there is no water there and the the
buildings stay completely without the
windows no people around because they
apparently have left already
they do not have any place to live
anymore and it is very uh strange and
terrifying to see kharkiv like this
because it is a big uh huge one and a
half million city and it ever always was
very lively with many people outside and
now you would see only long lines of
people standing in front of the shops
where they are trying to get some food
you mentioned the water being cut off
there what's the supply situation like
how long how much longer can you hold
out
it depends on on the on the region on
the districts in kharkiv so the
districts that were heavily bombarded
they are cut of the uh the uh initiative
supplies and the uh uh
infrastructure but the those where uh
there was still no bombardments for
example in my home i still do have
everything happiness to have electricity
and water and heating but of course we
understand that at some point russia
will continue uh trying to destroy the
critical infrastructure for the city
because uh they will probably try to
encircle kharkiv at one moment when they
regroup and get more forces because for
now it looks like the putin plan didn't
work out and now they are taking some
time to get more resource because
ukraine is fighting very effectively on
the ground at the moment what about
these humanitarian corridors that are
said to be in effect in kharkiv and
other ukrainian cities according to
russia can you confirm that
actually i haven't witnessed that that
myself i was on the streets yesterday
during the day and i continuously heard
the shellings and the explosions here
and there and i saw that the city of
chugguy and izum are in critical
situation because russian forces are
blockading them the the small towns
outside of parking and do not give any
possibilities to supply their something
and to get people out of here so i
really doubt that there is any kind of
such corridor and we have seen these
maps of russia that russian mod has
distributed uh showing the ways to to to
evacuate people to russia and belarus
and this is
nonsense which will never happen here
because it says
not possible situation russians are here
to kill ukrainians and now they propose
ukrainian people to flee to russia and
we all know here are very well aware of
the soviet-style uh tactics when they
had uh
taken the large
people the large numbers of people from
ukraine and transferred them to siberia
or some other places in russia
maria of diva for us there from the
european expert association
which focuses on ukrainian relations
with the eu and nato thank you for
joining us here on dw
thank you thank you
the hundreds of thousands of people
escaping the fighting have streamed into
the western ukrainian city of lev
it's become a massive bottleneck the
only direction to flee being west dw
correspondent alexandra vennaman met up
with some of them
we are here at the railway station in
reef and you can see how busy it is here
with long lines of people trying to get
on a train to the polish border mothers
with the small kids women with their
pets with
hastily packed suitcases and plastic
bags many of them seem to be traumatized
many of them are worried sick about the
loved ones that they're left behind
[Music]
we're from kharkiv this city is gone
i just have one question what was it all
for who benefits from destroying such a
beautiful city we once had a wonderful
mayor he's now turning over in his grave
you can't look at that's left of the
city without crying
i was born there i grew up there
i spent my whole life there
people there now have been left for dead
they're hiding in basements
i can't even think about it
they're sitting there without any
electricity water or heating my mother's
hiding in a cellar her mother is mario
she can't get hold of
never would have expected something like
this to happen especially from russia
and belarus i have so many relatives in
moscow
according to the city authorities it is
becoming increasingly difficult to
provide all the refugees with food and
clothes and first and foremost with the
place to stay
that is why
many people here are desperate to get
out even though they don't know
whether they will be able to come back
i don't know i never thought i'd have to
flee
i don't know where we will go whatever
god's plan is certainly to poland
we are not leaving forever we'll be back
for sure
many of the people we met are originally
from the russian-speaking part of the
country they told us they would never
expect russia to attack ukraine
they are angry and sad and some of them
have a clear message to vladimir putin
i don't understand why you are against
our membership in the eu and are now
literally pushing us towards europe
thank you very much but please it cannot
come at the cost of our lives and those
of russians only in a peaceful way
honestly i think putin knows he is sick
and will die soon and he wants to take
as many people with him as possible
we live in the 21st century we don't
live in the 20th century anymore during
the second world war we are civilized
people but how civilized is it for the
whole of ukraine to leave ukraine well
done you have liberated us thank you
the united nations says more than two
million people have now fled the
conflict in ukraine into neighbouring
countries
french firefighters are among those on
the polish ukrainian border helping the
refugees they say most of the people
arriving there are traumatized and
exhausted
efforts are underway to set up makeshift
hospitals in the region to care for the
new arrivals
volunteer michael heckmart has been
setting up those operating tents on the
polish border and has witnessed the huge
wave
of refugees good to see you michael uh
as i mentioned there
two million ukrainians have fled at
least half into poland have you ever
seen anything like it
i've never seen anything like this in my
entire life i didn't expect it to be
that huge and that big people who come
to the border often walk for 20 or more
kilometers because most of them i
brought are brought there by private
buses and the drivers are fit for the
army so they can't really bring them to
the exact order point
um they go on foot i haven't seen a five
kilometer line of people
waiting for the passport control ever in
my life
uh the tricky part is that the on the
ukrainian side of the border there is
barely any light it's dark it's super
cold
and these people stand there for about
seven to ten hours waiting to get to
poland
where
they'll be helped and
where they be safe
and what sort of a state are they in
when they arrive i i know you've been
setting up these these tents to to help
them what sort of a state are they in
i helped setting up medical tents in the
humanitarian aid point
at signia
they're mostly traumatized hypothermia
is probably
the
the most uh um
the the states that they're in
um children are tired women give birth
um stressed induced labor is very common
and uh cardiac arrest as well so um but
above all they don't really know where
they are and how long it is going to
take them to to cross the border so we
try to inform them as much as possible
calm them down and take care of them by
distributing food and drinks which they
can
consume standing outside and i guess a
lot of them don't know where they're
going how how do you decide where to go
um well the first thing is that when
they arrive in poland uh the polish
border control is very well organized
and there are buses uh provided by the
firefighters which bring them to the
reception point in the shemesh which is
a town 20 kilometers away from the
border and at that point they are able
to get food they're able to shower
they're able to take a rest they're able
to sleep there um and there are private
uh private cars and uh and people are
welcoming them uh at their homes and all
over poland basically so um there's uh
there's this center which connects
drivers and hosts with refugees so so
far there hasn't been a need to set up
any refugee camp in poland even though
over a million people cross the border
and what about psychological help for
these people what what have they been
telling you about their journey across
europe's biggest country with a war
going on around them
well i had i've been escorting a couple
of families with small children from
kiev through the border
we also managed to drive a bus through
the border full of children through the
border ourselves as in volunteers
and they're they're all scared they're
all scared of helicopters of airplanes
they're scared of
of bombs they're scared of death
basically so what we're trying to do is
we're trying to comfort them i'm not a
trained psychologist but there are
people helping them in premise in poland
on the on the reception at the reception
point
michael heckman one of the volunteers
helping refugees arriving from ukraine
thank you very much for giving us uh
this insight
into the conflict thank you
now look now at some other developments
in the war police in the russian city of
saint petersburg have detained a group
of women protesting against the invasion
of ukraine they were holding up posters
which can get you arrested appalled
about the deaths of russian soldiers
moscow has passed tough penalties for
speaking out against the military
credit rating agency fitch has
downgraded russian debt by six notches
to see
saying that a default is imminent the
agency says sanctions and trade
restrictions could undermine russia's
willingness to service its debt the
western measures have thrown the
country's financial markets into turmoil
following its invasion of ukraine
the united states has dismissed an offer
by poland to send its fleet of mig-29
fighter jets to ukraine
warsaw intended to give the soviet-era
aircraft to washington for use by the
ukrainian military
the pentagon was concerned that russia
could view the three-way deal as a
hostile move
but u.s president joe biden has
announced to ban on russian oil imports
in response to the invasion it comes as
the united states struggles with rising
fuel prices and inflation the us imports
only a small percentage of its oil from
russia but the ban is expected to push
oil prices even higher
here's what president biden had to say
today i'm announcing the united states
is targeting the main artery of russia's
economy
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
that means russian oil will no longer be
acceptable at u.s ports and the american
people will
deal another powerful blow to putin's
war machine
this is a move that has strong
bipartisan support for congress and i
believe in the country
americans have rallied support have
rallied to support their ukrainian
people and made it clear we will not be
part of subsidizing putin's war
the european union is more reluctant to
cut itself off from russian energy
brussels has laid out a plan to
drastically reduce imports by the end of
the year and cut them entirely by 2030
getting there won't be easy with
tensions between russia and the eu
escalating over the ukraine invasion it
may have to come much sooner
russia is now openly threatening to cut
off gas supplies to europe completely
this would lead to enormous bottlenecks
for the entire eu
gas is primarily used to heat homes in
ovens and production processes in power
plants to produce electricity a sudden
supply stop would push up energy prices
dramatically
prices for oil and gas have already
risen steeply consumers are feeling the
pressure at the petrol pumps and on
their gas bills
before the russian attack a megawatt
hour of gas cost 69 euros already more
expensive than consumers were used to
since then in just two weeks the price
of the eex energy exchange has rocked to
a record high of 335 euros and the
outlook is uncertain no one knows
whether russia will make good on its
threat and turn off the tap completely
the eu now wants to completely become
independent of russia repower eu is the
name of its new strategy
at its core diversifying energy
suppliers and drawing more from
renewable sources like solar and biogas
renewables give us the freedom to choose
an energy source
that is clean
cheap
reliable and ours
and instead of continuing to fund fossil
fuel imports and fund russian oligarchs
renewables create new jobs here in
europe the eu wants to replace
two-thirds of russian gas imports by the
end of the year an ambitious target this
will end our over dependency and give us
much needed room to maneuver two-thirds
by the end of this year
it's hard
bloody hard
but it's possible if we're willing to go
further and faster than we've done
before
the eu already has plans for its energy
transition but the war in ukraine has
officials startled forcing them to make
the switch far faster than previously
thought possible
the refugee exodus is seeing thousands
of ukrainians arrive here in berlin
every day it's called the capital
off-guard and is pushing resources to
the limit berlin says it can't cope
alone and has appealed for help from
other parts of the country
safe at last far from the war
the ukrainian refugees at this shelter
arrived in berlin a few days ago
traumatized and exhausted very few were
willing to talk to us
one woman from the besieged city of
kharkiv told us she finally managed to
get some sleep after arriving here she
can't hold back her tears
she lives in an apartment block on the
eighth floor
she told me she'll never leave she'd
rather die there
bombs and missiles are raining down on
the city
about 140 people have found temporary
shelter here
they're being cared for in part by an
ngo that operates shelters like these
its manager tells us time is of the
essence in this crisis
i got a call at 3am on sunday morning to
say that people would be moving in that
day
my colleagues worked like crazy in
constant shifts to get everything ready
two buses arrived carrying refugees in
the course of the day and we thought
that was it but by evening another bus
pulled up to our door with no advance
notice
after arriving at berlin's central train
station people are taken to their
accommodation
more than ten thousand refugees from
ukraine are arriving every day
the city has sounded the alarm saying it
can't cope
germany's interior minister has promised
to help
how to provide refugees from the war
zones with a place to stay in germany
naturally they can't all stay in berlin
the city can't cope on its own
the government is working on a plan to
coordinate the distribution of refugees
but all of germany states have pledged
to take people in
which is specific i just want to say
thank you to germany for helping us in
this situation
and i will try to help the country in
any way i can
it will take time to settle refugees
across germany until then berlin will
have to continue rolling out the help
for new arrivals
this is dw news live from berlin i'm ben
fazoul and thanks for watching i'll
leave you with some pictures taken by
photographers on the ground in ukraine
where the humanitarian crisis is
worsening for people across the country
[Music]
you